the Gathering was always meant to show a
united front to tackle extremism and
increase Regional security but the scars
of dispute remain obvious
at his opening remarks Indian Prime
Minister Narendra Modi delivered what
appeared to be criticism of his neighbor
Pakistan for today's
cross-border terrorism some countries
are using cross-border terrorism as the
instruments of their policies and they
give shelter to militants the SEO should
not hesitate to condemn such countries
relations between India and Pakistan
remain strained on a variety of issues
including Kashmir
the Rival neighbors have fought three
Wars for the contested region and there
is a risk of another
but this isn't the only rivalry that
could undermine the future of the
Shanghai cooperation organization
China and India have also had border
confrontations sparked by a disputed
area but despite a recent de-escalation
the dispute could still escalate
threatening a full-blown military
conflict
for now China is more concerned about
driving Global growth so that its
economy rebounds after its poor
performance following the lifting of
covid-19 restrictions
the world today is undergoing both
transformation and upheaval changes
unseen in a century are unfolding at a
faster Pace Human Society faces
unprecedented challenges Unity or split
peace or conflict cooperation or
confrontation
the Shanghai cooperation organization is
expanding the political trade and
security Alliance Iran has formally
joined the Gathering a significant step
towards ending its Global isolation
another political heavyweight in the
region Saudi Arabia is also joining the
organization the kingdom an important
oil producer and China the biggest
energy consumer are strengthening ties
their growing cooperation comes at a
moment when the United States appears to
be losing its influence